hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
und herzlich willkommen bei raspberry
wir sind in Türkei Youtube McDonald's
[Musik]
wir sind gerade in der Türkei in der
Nähe von nazarköy und ich möchte euch
heute zeigen wo und wie wir unseren
wunderschönen Baumschmuck herstellen ihr
kennt vielleicht den Spruch macht kein
Auge das bedeutet wenn zum Beispiel ihr
in eurem Garten einen wunderschönen Bau
habt der Früchte trägt und jemand kommt
und sagt oh der ist aber schön und am
nächsten Tag hängt da keine Blüten mehr
und gar nichts mehr dann hat ein böses
Auge auf euch geworfen und dann hat man
angefangen diese blauen Augen
herzustellen um praktisch diesen bösen
Blick entgegenzuwirken natürlich hat das
Ganze nichts religiöses aber so
symbolisch steht eben dafür dass es
einen beschützen soll und das ist einem
Gutes tun soll und ich finde es einfach
schön und dekorativ deswegen haben wir
seit kurzem eben unsere baumketten und
diesen Baum Schmuck der wird Hans
geknüpft und nur Augen die im nasser
Köln also in diesem NASA Dorf
hergestellt werden sind wirklich
original und da fahren wir jetzt mal
gemeinsam hin ich zeige euch mal kurz
das ist wirklich ein ganz ganz kleines
Dorf und ich zeige euch wie dort seid
Jahrzehnten einfach schon traditionell
handgemachte Augen entstehen
[Musik]
das ist jetzt eine und ihr habt gesehen
es ist eine richtige Handarbeit und will
ich sie kriegen nicht mehr als Touchs
und
gündemir max
[Musik]
ich habe gerade mit national ablagegerät
der Inhaberin von dem Unternehmen und
die sind zu fünft und die finden
natürlich auch ganz ganz schwer momentan
Mitarbeiter das ist nicht anders wie bei
uns in Deutschland weil es keiner machen
möchte weil das will ich eine harte
Arbeit ist und sie hatte selber gesagt
sie schafft 30 Ketten also sie selber
schafft vielleicht 30 Ketten am Tag und
im Monat schaffen sie ungefähr 1000 also
mehr schaffen sie wirklich nicht das ist
eine absolute Handwerkskunst und auch
eine sehr sehr harte Arbeit ich also ich
war vorhin in diesem Atelier drin wo sie
denn das ganze Feuer machen und dort zu
arbeiten das muss wirklich das ist
wirklich hart richtig extrem hat und ich
finde es wunderschön weil es etwas
Kulturelles ist es ist nichts gläubiges
also es ist halt nichts mit dem Glauben
zu tun es ist etwas Kulturelles in der
Türkei und äh in der Region hier und nur
Ketten die hier produziert sind sind
wirklich original nazaretten deswegen
heißt das Ding wirklich auf Nasar hier
und ich finde es wunderschön und gerade
in den Bäumen ist es ein tolles
Lichtspiel wenn wir ähm an die Bäume
hängt wenn die ersten Sonnenstrahlen
kommen sie richtig schön aus auch bei
uns im
Valley wunderschön und deswegen etwas
ganz Besonderes
ich zeige euch jetzt mal hier im Nazari
wie wir unseren Baumschmuck für
raspberry selbst herstellen mit dem
typischen
damit Ihr unseren Garten und knüpfen das
jetzt
[Musik]
hier bei makrameknöpfen machen wir es
jetzt so wir möchten nämlich dass unsere
Ketten sich so ein bisschen eindrehen
deswegen düpfen wir immer von einer
Seite wenn ihr was gerade vielleicht
noch knüpfen wollt dann macht ihr einmal
von links und einmal von rechts aber
wenn sie es drehen soll wenn ihr Spirale
wie so eine DNA sozusagen dann immer nur
von einer Seite knüpfen
[Musik]
fertig ist unser Baumschmuck
ich habe einen mit einer Blume gemacht
und sie hat einen mit einem Tisch
gemacht und ich finde so ein Baumschmuck
das schmeckt nicht nur einen Baum
sondern auch Wände in der Outdoor ich
habe z.B auf meiner Terrasse sondern
richtig schönen Baumschmuck sieht
einfach überall schön aus mit diesem
Makramee Elisa türkische
Pizza
nein
alles handgemachte
[Musik]
das sind jetzt unsere NASA Ketten
auseinander hier nach Waghäusel
vielleicht auch bald bei euch im Garten
sieht richtig cool aus ein richtig
schönes an so einem schönen Sommerabend
wenn die Sonne so ein bisschen flach
rein scheint dann glitzern die dann ist
es wie so ein cooles Lichtspiel sieht
man den Bäumen richtig cool aus wir
haben das jetzt auch an unseren Oliven
Bäumen dran etwas mediterranes an
Blickfang in Eyecatcher und wie gesagt
vielleicht auch bald bei euch im Garten
war eine richtig tolle Story schön dass
wir uns mitgekommen seid demnächst folgt
auch ein Block das heißt die ganze
Stories die wir in der Türkei erlebt
haben im ganzen Team zusammen das heißt
bleibt dran abonniert den Kanal und
schalte das Video an mit richtig ganz
ganz toller Block bleibt jetzt kommt
noch ein richtig cooles Gewinnspiel
so das ist jetzt die letzte Kette also
war ein richtig cooles Video und ihr
könnt jetzt noch was gewinnen und zwar
schreibt einfach in die Kommentare was
euch im Video am besten gefallen hat
würde es zu Hause auch aufhängen ja du
kriegst du kriegst zwei blaue Augen von
mir wenig es ist gar kein Thema im
gynige ich jetzt zusammen übrigens jetzt
nach Schweden für vier Tage man Schweden
unsicher oder werden auch ein tolles
Video darüber reden
ja also macht's gut vielen vielen Dank
dass Sie bis zum Schluss dran geblieben
seid und zwar wenn es wirklich eine Ehre
eine ganz tolle Story macht's gut macht
es besser ihr wach vorbei Murat und euer
Günni
[Musik]